foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists oh we have something special
for you today malabama's here hi
everybody TK Coleman here to say yes for
Less oh we got the rest of our team here
in the studio coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about in-house
storage and where to store excess stuff
we also have an outstanding lightning
round listener tip and added value
segment for you you can check out the
full two hour maximal edition of episode
367 where we answer four times the
questions and we dive deep into several
simple living segments that private
podcast episode is out right now at
patreon.com the minimalist your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because say it
with me y'all advertisements
[ __ ] oh Jessica asked me to make one
note here at the beginning of the
podcast
if you do ever see an ad on our YouTube
channel it is not our ad it'd be like if
you saw an ad on Facebook so we don't
monetize our YouTube channel because we
don't want to Pepper our creations with
ads if YouTube ever decides to turn on
an ad on one of our videos it was
without our say without our permission
we're grateful for the opportunity to
upload videos on their platform we'd
prefer that they continue to keep our
Channel advertisement free let's start
with our callers y'all if you have a
question or comment for our show give us
a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast that the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Colette hi
my name is Colette I'm from Washington
DC my husband is a minimalist like me
but she has seven boxes that we keep in
our basement storage closet it bothers
me
um and I've told him but he doesn't want
to do anything about it is there an
effective or loving way to try to
explain to him that this bothers me I'm
willing and open to try anything I've
tried over the years but nothing has
worked so far
so we're going to get Colette on the
phone here because I want to know about
what is in these seven boxes that are
hiding out in the basement in this
storage space or impromptu storage space
so Professor Sean if you could get
Colette on the phone I'd love to talk to
her about this
seven boxes cluttering hello hey Colette
Joshua Milburn and the minimalists here
TK Ryan are here how you doing
I'm good how are you guys awesome
awesome thanks for doing this
yeah thank you for letting me do it our
pleasure I appreciate your question I
I'm really curious about these seven
boxes that are hiding in your basement
my first question is do you even know
what is in them and does your husband
know what's in those boxes
I know it's in them yes
um
it's mainly just um some books
um some old paperwork some old cards
um some old Medical
uh paperwork
some old school work
I think that's pretty much it okay so
it's uh we have these clutter coffins
down there it's a bunch of things that
have essentially been rendered useless
to you at least right and you would like
them to be out of the way it sounds like
they're taking up space why does it
bother you that they're taking up space
down there
um the question uh it bothers me because
our home is pretty tidy we don't have a
lot of clutter and both myself and my
husband really enjoy that
um we can tidy up quickly it reduces our
anxiety
um and it just I feel like it's
something that can be done simply and
just taken care of and we don't have to
have these boxes that we move with every
time we move for the last seven years oh
wow so every time you move in the last
seven years you don't open these boxes
you don't use the things in these boxes
they simply or they travel from one
storage space to another you know quite
often we have these storage spaces
throughout our houses basements or
attics or closets or spare bedrooms or
we turn our regular rooms into storage
space as well and you said that it's
clutter and most of your home just
doesn't have clutter in it and so this
when our homes are filled with clutter
we usually don't notice the Clutter that
much it's it's hard to see a needle in a
haystack but it's harder to see a needle
in a needle stack and so if you just
have tons of clutter you may not notice
a little bit of clutter but right now
what you're saying is I've got this
clutter now clutter is anything that
gets in the way of your well-being and
so those boxes may not be cluttered to
your husband and I think that's where
the the disconnect is right now for him
it's not getting in the way of his
well-being it's not even really getting
in the way it's sort of out of sight out
of mind but of course as you've
experienced Colette the boxes are not
out of sight out of mind they're in your
mind it's creating this mental clutter
that you have to have to deal with and
so yes I experienced this in my own life
I um we bought a new house earlier this
year Bex and I did and she has more
stuff than me that she uses she has some
camping gear that we could theoretically
fit somewhere in our home I could cram
it into a closet somewhere we don't have
a garage we don't have a basement we
don't really have a functional attic so
I could find some space for all of her
camping gear but what we decided and
she'd be fine with that by the way she
just put that in our little Closet in
our bedroom she'd be fine with keeping
in there but it bothered me and so I
simply asked hey can we figure out a
solution together would you be willing
to Simply help me clear this clutter I
recognize that it's not clutter to you
it happens to be my issue it is clutter
for me and so I'm willing to move it to
a storage locker and pay for a storage
locker for a period of time until we
have the space here at our home which
say we're actually saving up money to
get a shed in the future but right now
we're we're spending some money on an
outside storage locker so that I don't
have the clutter in my home and that
might sound crazy as one of the
minimalists whether you have a storage
locker yeah it's it's really about
getting the Clutter out of my home so
it's not in my way but I also recognize
that and Ryan taught me this a while ago
that when I have a problem with
something in our relationship the worst
thing I can do is make it my partner's
problem as well yeah and so Ryan I I
don't want to I don't want Colette to
turn this into her husband's problem
because it feels like oh if he were just
to deal with his problem then everything
would be fine and that may be true but I
think the truth is Colette this may be
for you to deal with yeah
Coletta I'm I'm curious like is there
have you asked your husband why he's
kind of holding on to these boxes is it
a matter of it's sentimental or is it
more of uh he just doesn't have the time
to go through it have you had that
conversation with him at all
yeah I have um and it's both of those
things like um some sentimental things
and then some things he's saying oh I
might need it one day let's not throw it
out like I might need it I might want to
look at it one day it's like I mean
seven years
he hasn't even opened the box wow yeah I
um I relay with that because I certainly
had the boxes unopened that used to
travel with me from place to place
um you know a while ago yeah I love I
love your idea Josh about
um trying to find a solution together
because this isn't about like you know
either Colette has to suffer or her
husband has to suffer it's about like
how can they both come to a common
ground and maybe Colette like pitching
it to him about renting a storage unit
to get these things out of the house
um if that's worth it to him to spend
that money every month then you know
maybe that's what you all do but I'm
willing to bet that it's probably not
worth the money that uh he would have to
spend on the storage unit yeah I've got
some stats on storage units I mean so
our the the storage industry especially
in America so ninety percent of all
storage units are in the United States
of America which is a staggering
statistic so I don't think consumerism
is a uniquely American problem but
amassing of consumables of material
possessions of excess
that is a uniquely American problem we
amass it in all of these storage lockers
so for me I'm not against the storage
industry there's 1.6 billion square feet
of storage space that means if you put
every American in a storage unit you'd
still have extra space left over wow so
there's a lot of storage space out there
I'm not against that industry if it's
useful Bex uses her camping equipment
all the time it falls within her
boundaries I wouldn't however just take
seven boxes of random things we don't
use and simply put it in a storage unit
because the cost of that is too high
you're just spending any money on these
things that are essentially useless to
both of us the problem right now with
your husband is he doesn't realize the
pain that you're experiencing because
he's not experiencing that same pain or
if he is maybe he doesn't even realize
that he's experiencing that pain TK do
you have any insights for Colette how's
it going Colette
good how are you good
um have you told your husband how you
feel like not so much about the stuff
like we need to get rid of it but have
you expressed to him how much it bothers
you and overwhelms you
um I have and I think it's like a broken
record at this point how does he respond
to it
he doesn't want to discuss it
yeah when when Ryan asked you the
question um one of the things you
mentioned is that some of the stuff he
wants on a just in case basis some of
the stuff he just you know has to go
through what do you think he would say
if you were to say to him something like
hey look I really want you to get what
you need out of your stuff and I also
really want to protect myself from the
way it's affecting me and weighing me
down
some of the stuff you probably should
keep some of this stuff you might be
more willing to give up than you think
can we put a date on the calendar even
if it's a month from now where we can
just take some time and go through it
together and see what we're willing to
do and what you need what do you think
he'd say to that
he might be open to it
[Music]
to it I I the reason I I propose that is
because
sometimes when when you can get him to
state that why and you can have a
discussion about that why it may be
possible to negotiate some agreements
between the two of you that allow him to
fulfill that why in a different way so
if he's got some just in case items
maybe maybe it can be an agreement
between the two of you of like hey look
how about if in the future we ever need
that I'll I'll buy it for you or we
could make this kind of agreement in
order to alleviate that concern and
maybe there can be some alternative
agreements that can help him find some
different ways to meet that why
um that's a good idea and Colette I also
think that it's really important to set
up boundaries here because we're not
talking about we don't want to go into a
conversation like this and say hey you
need to get rid of these seven boxes
right it's not about an ultimatum it's
about helping him understand that maybe
some of this is junk some of it's
non-essential but it's adding some sort
of value to your life maybe it's
sentimental items but having a hundred
thousand sentimental items really
diminishes the sentimentality of those
items right by keeping a dozen of them
instead of a hundred or a thousand
sentimental items you actually get far
more value from the sentimental items
that you keep I know when I was going
through my mom's stuff that was one
thing that was really important to me
and then the other boundary was
okay maybe seven boxes is too much but
maybe and you need to understand this
maybe zero boxes is not enough for him
yeah
and so
maybe we can get this down to one box
and that'd be wonderful and you'll get
more value from it you won't have to get
an outside storage locker you can put it
in your basement and you can have it in
a really nice bin even you go out and
you can you know find a nice
aesthetically pleasing bin where it
looks good doesn't feel like clutter for
you you sort through it together you
have your own little version of a
packing party where you're going through
these memory triggers you can even have
conversations about the photos and the
artwork or anything that's in there you
can laugh at the absurdity together of
why was I holding on to this receipt or
why was I holding on to this 14 year old
tax information and you can make it
playful because right now it's not
playful at all it's the opposite right
yeah and he feels like I don't have any
control and she's trying to have some
sort of power over me and that creates
resistance in the relationship and
that's not what you want you simply want
to clear the Clutter yeah yeah exactly
anytime I hear about disagreements like
this I always think about that book
non-violent communication and Colette if
you haven't if you haven't read it I
would highly recommend reading it
because what it does is it helps uh
situations like this where one person
has an issue
but the other person does not have the
issue and you know if you go to your
husband and you're like hey you know
your boxes are offending me or they're
making me upset like that is going to
probably put him on the defense where
you know if you approach it in a way
where you're like hey honey we've been
together for you know five ten years
whatever it is and I really need your
help with something and I know I've
asked for your help on this before
um but I really
um and just really asking for you to
help me with this situation and you know
it's about those boxes like they really
um they cause me a little bit of anxiety
I know they're important to you and um I
want you to to have what's important to
you um but I'm just wondering if we
could find a solution together like when
you approach it like that it's more you
can kind of enroll him into helping come
up with a solution rather than you know
kind of pointing the finger and saying
hey these are your boxes you need to do
something about them well one last thing
really quickly Colette in reference to
what Ryan just said sometimes it can
help to write those kinds of things down
if you've had a conversation over and
over again that's been ineffective maybe
writing can give not only you a little
more control over your tone so that
you're not talking about things in the
Heat of the Moment but in a way that's
more reflective and pensive and
empathetic but also for him it can give
him the space to take in your words
without you being right there to read
and respond to the reaction he has and
that might be something that's used for
I know it might sound crazy to write a
letter to your spouse but that might
create a little space so that he can
process in a way that um allows him to
give a better reaction
yeah that makes sense and um I do have
that book Ryan so I think I'll you know
look over it again for some tips yeah
it's a good one it's a good one for sure
it is and if you're looking for some
more boundaries you can always download
that free ebook we have the 16 rules for
living with less I think some of those
especially as you're going through the
stuff the just in case rule the No Junk
rule the just for win rule the
seasonality rule the spontaneous
combustion rule I think all of those
will really help you with your
conversations with them you could even
have I mean it's a short book you can
read in less than half an hour it's uh
the 16 rules for living with less you
can find that over at the
minimalists.com Colette thank you so
much for your question we appreciate you
thank you so much and I love you guys
you guys are great oh we love you too
thanks again thanks Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
questions from social media yes indeed
now during the lightning round that's
where we do our best to answer questions
of the short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims and the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you like and you can
find all of our minimal maxims over at
minimalmaxims.com looks like Lisa has a
question for us how do I keep stress at
Bay during a big move no matter how much
I try to plan and organize it all feels
so overwhelming Professor Sean let's get
60 seconds on the clock for my good
friend Ryan Nicodemus oh it's me all
right let's go um man I uh well my pithy
answer is this is uh
stress as a weapon people use to abuse
themselves yes so what I'll say is that
when the stress arises within you it's
very easy to use that feeling of anxiety
to use that feeling of stress to beat
ourselves up and I personally used to
tell myself that that was virtuous
because I'm taking that negative feeling
I'm dwelling on it I'm using it to make
me feel a certain way but the problem is
this is that when you abuse yourself
with stress it doesn't help you really
do anything different in fact it can be
paralyzing so what do you do with that
stress you acknowledge it you look at
what it is trying to show you because
Stress and Anxiety is a symptom so the
question is is what is that symptom
trying to get you to do and you know
what yes it's getting trying to get you
to be organized and to move and to uh
come up with some type of boundary to
help the mood go smoothly so don't use
your stress as a weapon against yourself
ah that was perfect timing yeah TK
Coleman we got 60 seconds on the clock
for you what do you got for Lisa when
you resent your fillings you resist the
wisdom that they provide we speak of
fillings as if they are good or bad but
what that really means is it's Pleasant
or unpleasant it's uncomfortable or it's
joyful but it doesn't mean it is evil
for me to have this sensation or that
this sensation is evidence that I am an
evil person it's okay to have an
uncomfortable feeling without condemning
yourself as being an evil person for
having it I feel jealous I feel sad I
feel angry I feel stressed what's right
about that jealousy what's right about
that anger what's right about that
stress when you answer that question
then you can look at that feeling and
say thank you for pointing out to me the
pain that I was experiencing as an
indicator of some way in which my life
was out of alignment now I can get it
aligned and I can do what I need to do
and I can say to that feeling thank you
Forget Me On Track hmm yes
Lisa I got something pithy for you let's
do this so of course in your question
you say no matter how much I organize
and plan
I just feel so stressed I would say
maybe you feel so stressed because
you're organizing and planning all the
time organizing is well planned hoarding
and so we're just constantly moving
around all of our excess stuff if we
have too much it doesn't matter how much
you organize it yes you're still going
to feel stressed the opposite of that
though is you don't want to renounce the
stress you don't want to say I want no
stress for the rest of my life you might
feel like you want no stress for the
rest of your life but then what the heck
would you do with your life some level
of stress shows up and it shows you what
you want to do in order to move forward
renouncing the stress is not what you
want to do clinging to the stress
amassing the stress building more stress
is not what you want to do you want to
experience the stress and let it flow
through you you could hold on to it for
a moment but don't cling to it you can
let it go
we got a bunch more to talk about oh we
got a home tour as well we're gonna dive
into that we got TK's tweet of the week
we got the ambassad or trash it segment
but we do have some patrons who have
joined us on a live stream let's check
in with one of them right now I'm
Alabama you got any questions for us we
do we have a question that comes from
Catherine she says my body fluctuates
due to thyroid issues is storing various
sizes of clothes okay when does it
become clutter now you have to just wear
medium and that's it
otherwise you're doing it wrong you have
to wear your clothes whether they fit or
not extra medium is uh is unacceptable
now here's the thing like we plan Four
Seasons in our life right now that can
be literal Seasons I wear a winter coat
in the winter if I wear that in July in
Southern California
it is going to be inappropriate for me
so it's not that
you have clothes that are inappropriate
all the time but you have some clothes
that are going to be more appropriate
for a particular season of your life and
that's okay unless you feel like holding
on to those clothes is getting in the
way of your well-being that's the only
time they become clutter and so
we use the seasonality rule it's in the
minimalist rule book you can download it
for free over at the minimalists.com we
also call that the 90 90 rule have I
used this thing in the last 90 days
if not am I going to use it in the next
90 days be honest with yourself yeah and
if the answer is no then I give myself
permission to Let It Go but for you you
might need to expand that rule because
these aren't rules they're tools they're
boundaries you can set up for yourself
and so what is the appropriate amount of
time for you to understand that okay I'm
not actually going to use this piece of
clothing again and I can give myself
permission to let it go maybe it's six
months maybe it's nine months you get to
decide what that boundary is for you and
you can set up the boundary so that you
can let go of anything that falls
outside of that boundary that's being
compassionate to yourself ooh yeah
compassionate to yourself that's yeah
that's great I mean that's that's the
question I would be asking Catherine
like do you need to show yourself a
little bit of compassion right now
because your uh your body does fluctuate
um or are you looking at your clothes
because deep down like you know or you
don't know whether or not you can get
rid of some of those those clothing
items yeah yeah and sometimes it's as
simple as making the distinction between
for me or for someone else after the too
much
is it too much for me or is it too much
for someone else and sometimes we can
know what's too much for me at the level
of visceral experience but what leaves
the question mark there is what will
other people think of me people that
don't know all the details of my story
when they come and see how much stuff I
have you know um my wife and I because
of you know my injury and me going
through PT
um you know I can't lift as much you
know as much as I used to you know what
I mean I used to have no limitations
with what I could live but uh the gym
would run out of Weights when he was
there why did his voice get so deep
but but there have been these moments
where maybe um my wife is pulling my
luggage or she's carrying a box and I'm
walking next to my wife right and she's
the small petite girl and she's carrying
my stuff and I'm walking next to her and
then a few guys walk by and I just
everything in me wants to be like hey
look man like I gotta get injury that's
why she carry on my stuff you know what
I mean and so sometimes we get these
insecurities because we know that our
lives look funny in a way that doesn't
make sense to other people and you just
gotta not apologize for who you are and
what you need I don't need to explain
myself to those people let them look at
me where it is what it is all that
matters is that her and I are cool you
know what I mean yeah amen I got one
more rule for you I'm gonna save it for
the private podcast it's called the
repurchase rule we're going to talk
about that because I want to do a deep
dive on that with Ryan we're constantly
coming with these new tools these new
boundaries that help us better
um hold on to the things that add value
let go of the things that don't and
bring things into our life that's serve
us for a particular season it's called
the repurchase rule we'll talk about
that on the private podcast in addition
to the photo Friday home tour the sucky
ad segment TK the week you were gone for
episode 364. you were sick and Wendy was
here you totally missed uh on the
private podcast I I wrapped a Pusha T
verse oh man yeah I mean you got to go
back and listen to it but it was the
worst ad I had ever heard it was
actually no it was the most
disappointing ad that I had ever heard
what I have one that now tops it I can't
wait worst advertisement of all time oh
wow so check that out yeah
patreon.com the minimalist malibam what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
hi Russell Island this is Molly from
Michigan what we do is we will buy
things
on trips that aren't
stereotypical souvenirs they're more
everyday type items so for example on
our honeymoon in Ireland my husband
bought a tweed jacket and it's great he
wears it in the fall he wears it in the
spring it's a perfect jacket for
that time
and it's just a little too cold for
sport coat but it's too warm for a big
pea coat a big puffy down coat
and it really fits a spot in his
wardrobe
and he was able to buy something there
that's unusual not the kind of thing you
would get here and then every time he
rolls it it reminds him of our trip but
it's not just from jet ski all right
y'all before we get to our added value
segment this week real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
actually I have two things because Black
Friday is coming up real soon we have a
Black Friday video we'll put a link to
it in the show notes you gotta check it
out it's over on YouTube and it's called
let's talk about Black Friday it's one
of the most popular things we've done on
YouTube a lot of people find Value in it
because we talk about not just the
origins of Black Friday but how Black
Friday is absolutely making us miserable
the expectations of others or the
expectations set forth by corporations
often make us feel inadequate insecure
ashamed incomplete and it's creating
this incompletion in our lives which
then fuels the consumerism of Black
Friday act now supplies are limited door
Buster sales you can opt out of that and
that video will show you how it's called
let's talk about Black Friday you can
find it in the show notes or just look
for that over on our YouTube channel
youtube.com the minimalist also coming
up our last Sunday Symposium of the Year
November 27th me Ryan TK and the rest of
the team will be here in La 200 seats
only it's the last Sunday Symposium
we've had three magical Sunday
symposiums and they just keep getting
better it's not our intention to make
them better but they just do it just
keeps every Sunday Symposium I'm like oh
that was my favorite one no no this
one's my favorite one yeah that's it's
pretty it is pretty special well it's
sold out but we just released 20 new or
20 tickets free tickets half the tickets
are free half are paid if you can afford
to buy a ticket that will get a ticket
for someone else who is in need or if
you can't afford it show up you just
need a free ticket you can go to Sunday
symposium.com we'd love to have you
there help us build this community
together one thing I noticed this last
one friend of mine came and she
mentioned that I was amazed by how many
she came by herself and she said I was
amazed by how many people actually just
show up by themselves yeah and it's that
deep need for Community you can connect
with other people you're not forced to
we don't say Hey you have to talk to
your neighbor for three minutes or
anything like that but you can show up
by yourself you can grab one free ticket
you can be there you can have this
community experience with us we never
know what to expect except it's been a
magical time every time November 27th at
noon downtown Los Angeles the dynasty
typewriter Sunday symposium.com is where
you can find the free tickets get them
before they are gone it's the last one
of the year yeah for our added value
segment this week
I was thinking about what is one
possession earlier on the private
podcast we were talking about the
repurchase Rule and if I were to lose
something would I repurchase it what is
what is the most valuable or most useful
item that I have in my home and
certainly one of the most useful items I
have is a pull-up bar yeah the one I use
called The Perfect Pull up now I can
tell you inflation's really getting to
us because I remember I spent 20 bucks
on this it was 1995 and they're 32
dollars now for the same pull-up bar
yeah but it's well worth it it's
something I use every day I hang from it
constantly I'm hanging and it's really
helps with my shoulders if you have any
neck pain shoulder pain back pain
hanging from it for an extended period
of time and then also just doing
pull-ups throughout the day every time I
go to the bathroom I'm gonna do six
Pull-Ups real quick right and it's on
the way to the bathroom it's not like I
have to exert a whole lot more effort
and it's built this beautiful routine
into my days
and for 30 bucks it's something I use
every single day of my life you can see
it here on the screen if uh if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well it's for 30 bucks
it's the thing that adds the most value
to my life and I was thinking about this
the other day if I needed to if I lost
it if it broke it's the first I would
replace it immediately because I get so
much value from it that doesn't mean
well you get value from it well yeah
only if you use it just hanging up a
pull-up bar on your house doesn't do
anybody anything in fact it could become
clutter it could get in the way for you
it could become an eyesore because well
it looks fine I would prefer that it was
invisible and so yes it takes up a
little bit of visual space right but
it's something I use every day and I get
immense value from it yeah thank you
yeah I have one too I I wanted to know I
wanted to ask you directly do you ever
use the pull down thing you see how it
is in the photo no but my wife does
really what does she do to do that like
does she do something is it just because
she's shorter or no no it's because she
ha she doesn't can't do a bunch of
pull-ups at once and so it's almost like
doing an assisted pull-up essentially so
it's allowing you to pull but you have
your feet on the ground so you're not
pulling your full body weight all the
way up yeah and it also it does work a
different muscle group in the back when
you do when you do those yeah the when
you yeah
whatever position that's called
I used to do those as well like I would
do pull-ups I don't have I don't have a
perfect pull-up I need to get one I
actually so we moved to this this
apartment and it was during the pandemic
um I couldn't find a perfect pull-up bar
so I got one that very similar to what
we brought on tour with us in 2014 yeah
and um I kind of yeah I do miss the
being able to like have a couple
different exercises with that with that
bar anyway I use it every day and it's
uh it's one of the things that adds the
most value to my it's probably my most
useful possession by the way TK we got a
bunch more surprise questions on the
private podcast this week like how do I
keep laundry supplies and cleaning
supplies to a minimum how do I opt out
of the holiday gift exchange at work
what is the minimalist's new repurchase
Rule and how will it help you let go
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast at patreon.com the minimalist or
click the link in the description that's
our show for today y'all if you leave
here today with just one message
whether it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it